اظن ان
العلاقه بين الشاعر والخطاب السردي عموما
قصه قصيره
مع ما يشاء في الخطاب الاعلامي العربي
اولا في تاريخ الادب كثير من الروائيين
الكبار كانوا شعراء وكثير منهم ضلوا شعراء
وهم يمارسون الكتابه
لكن اللي علينا ان نقول بان القصيده
رغم قيمه يعني الشاعر هو نشيد الانسانيه
الاول
الاجناس الادبيه كلها
والرواء الكبير الروائي العظيم لابد ان
يكون في قلبي
لا يمكن الذي لا يقرا الشعر ولا يحب الشعر
حتى في صناع القرار حتى القاده والزعماء
اذا لم يكن في قلبهم وفي دواخنهم شاعر او
حساسيه شعريه معينه لا يمكن ان يكون
ديمقراطيه لان الشعر هو يزرع فيه من نزرعه
الانسان ولذلك يتحولون الى طهات والجانب
الشعري يزرع هذه اللمسه وهذه الروح
اكيد انا اظن العلاقه بين
والروايه ليست علاقه خصام علاقه تكامل
عندما اكتب الشعر وينتقل لاكتب روايه على
سبيل المثال ليس نوعا من تغيير المحطه
السفر ونفس السفر ونفسه انما اغيره رصيفا
برصيف داخل نفسه محطه وفي نفس الاتجاه